bonjour à tous tous nous avons en
mémoire ce qu'a été l'année 2021 c'est à
dire pour beaucoup d'entre nous une
année difficile des deuils la maladie et
cette inquiétude collective cette
angoisse collective qui vient d'une
épidémie dont on n'avait pas vu
l'appareil depuis plus de 100 ans
c'est dans cet esprit que nous abordons
2022 et nous savons tous ce à quoi nous
sommes confrontés c'est à dire d'abord
une nouvelle vague qui fait
encore beaucoup plus de contaminations
qu'aucune des vagues précédentes
des centaines de milliers des records
battus tous les jours mais pour
l'instant je dis pour l'instant sans
qu'aucun d'entre nous n'a la certitude
que ça va durer pour l'instant nous
savons que la situation à l'hôpital et
maîtriser parce que nous avons réussi à
vacciner ce qui permet de freiner les
conséquences les plus dramatiques de la
maladie et cela c'est à dire regarder
les choses en face et se doter des armes
nécessaires pour que l'on puisse
affronter l'avenir et l'affronter
positivement cela c'est la même chose
pour l'ensemble de la société française
pour l'ensemble de notre économie pour
l'ensemble de notre système scolaire et
de formation de nos universités de la
formation professionnelle j'ai même
envie de dire pour l'éducation populaire
tout cela nous le vivons avec en tout
cas je souhaiterais que nous ne vivions
avec une certitude c'est que la france
est un des pays les mieux armés au monde
pour affronter les temps qui viennent ce
basculement des temps qui est provoquée
par l'épidémie évidemment mais qui
provoquait aussi par l'explosion du
numérique des data
du génie génétique toutes ces sciences
nouvelles qui sont en train de changer
la vie de chacun d'entre nous la france
est mieux armé que les autres elle peut
saisir ces occasions la répartition de
la production dans le monde par exemple
avant c'était en extrême orient parce
qu'on savait qu'on y trouverait les prix
des le coût du travail le plus bas
aujourd'hui on peut aller beaucoup plus
loin et un pays comme le nôtre peut
rivaliser et peut-être même se trouvait
en tête devant ces régions du monde mais
à tout cela cet optimisme cette capacité
de saisir les difficultés et de relever
les défis
cette possibilité d'être un modèle dans
le monde à tout cela il y à une
condition cette condition c'est notre
unité
si nous savons nous rassembler si nous
savons éviter les risques ou les dangers
que représentent ces guerres civiles
perpétuelle la détestation d'une partie
de la france contre l'autre au nom de
toutes les
prétexte de tous les prétextes de
situations de tous les prétextes
d'origine de tous les prétextes de
religion si nous sommes capables de
former un pays uni alors j'en ai la
certitude rien ne nous résistera je
disais cela il ya dix ans et je le dis
encore aujourd'hui un pays uni rien ne
lui résiste cette volonté de former un
pays solidaire et soudé c'est la
condition même pour que la france soit
demain en tête comme elle a le droit
d'espérer l'être dans le monde voilà les
voeux que je forme naturellement cd veut
collective mais chacune chacun d'entre
vous avec tout les espoirs de vie qui
sont les vôtres pour vous même pour vos
enfants pour la génération qui précède
je souhaite la meilleure année possible
bonne année 2022